[Musik]
servus servus servus servus servus
halten sie auch zusammen
eine Schmutzkampagne von den Vocal
Berlinern gewesen
also inhaltlich meine ich inhaltlich
das ist nur eine pure Politik mache
jetzt wollen sie uns Winnetou wegnehmen
und dann holt einfangen
[Musik]
oder sonst irgendwas also so kommen wir
momentan unser Land
als Bundeskanzler was würden Sie sagen
und ich meine so viele Erinnerungslücken
wie er hat hat er ja kanzlermaterialien
glauben Sie denn Hubert Aiwanger dass
sein Bruder das war am Ende
dort zu nehmen
jetzt dann doch es ist schon so ein
bisschen ne der Hund hat die
Hausaufgaben gefressen genau
wer hat in der Jugend mehr Scheiße
gebaut Hubert Aiwanger oder die
klimakleber
der hat momentan reagieren muss
als Jugendlicher das so viel können wir
sagen okay
vielleicht die Juden die sich davon
schon irgendwie antisemitisch
angegriffen
eigentlich nicht
[Musik]
einfacher
wir kennen uns ja bereits aber bei ihnen
muss man ja trotzdem fragen erinnern Sie
sich an mich
ich habe sogar 26 Fragen an
glaube ich glaube das ist 100 hoch
ich würde mich gerne auf die offene
Stelle als ihr Kommunikationsberater
bewerben
servus benannt war das ein Jahr wenn das
doch so ein einschneidendes Erlebnis war
warum können Sie sich erinnern
Hubert einwanger wollte leider nicht mit
mir reden aber ich versuch's weiter und
schicke jetzt meinen Bruder
Florian Köster
[Applaus]
[Musik]
hallo dies ist die automatische endcard
von Oliver Welke und der heute-show
leider ist das Video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den Kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres Video
anschauen vielen Dank
[Musik]